hey Leute mein Name ist Larissa und
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ist
[Musik]
ja Laser Luke oh du geisteskrank
ehrenloser
wow
wie viel würdest du deinen Kanal
verkaufen ich schwöre auf das gerade
meiner Mutter für kein Geld dieser Geld
würdest du verkaufen
würde ich sagen 100 Millionen
en mal den ersten Teilnehmer in unsere
Konferenz einen schönen guten Abend ihre
Frage an die Kanzlerin
hallo ja wir hören sie
um auf den Punkt zu kommen hier habe ich
eine Zahnbürste die 65 € gekostet habe
ich finde die absoluten Dreck wenn man
draufklickt und sie nicht angeht dann
bedeutet das dass der Akku leer ist
dafür braucht man nicht so eine
riesenanzeige den ganzen Raum erleuchtet
das ist schon wieder zum Punkt der kotzt
mich an das ist schon wieder
Stromverbindung auf Kosten der Nutzer da
haben sie recht aber reinheitlichkeit
gefühlt hiermit ist auch fast jeden Tag
noch Belag drauf und ich mache es
richtig ich habe mich sogar Tutorials im
Internet angeguckt wie man sich mit
richtig okay also dieser Bürsten kommt
runter
ist das echt Alter krass zugeschaltet in
unserem cdu-video krass
ich habe wieder nie angerufen
[Musik]
und wie das Cash young
was schreiben sie denn so wahrscheinlich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
absolut Cabrio 100% Cabrio seid ihr
dabei
ich liebe dich
[Musik]
menschlich gesehen ziemlich sympathisch
das ist die russischen
[Musik]
was reimt sich auf NATO dein
Lieblingscafé
Siri
ich bin auch nicht im Video ist nicht in
Deutschland gestanden tatsächlich glaube
ich in Amerika und wir alle beide wissen
ich kann kein Englisch wir sehen uns
gute Nacht
schlaf gut
aber sonst geht's dir gut oder
hier sagt die ganze Zeit Schoko Zitrone
Alter
[Musik]
eine Frage was könnte das bedeuten wenn
eine Frau das postet die ich gern habe
she remember
drei Dinge die jeder macht Müsli direkt
aus der Packung Essen unter der Dusche
singen Spaß
was suchst du denn jetzt Fernseher
[Musik]
kommen
bis wohin schwimmt ihr sag mal ganz
ehrlich es gibt keinen genetisch
erklärbaren menschlichen Grund zu fünft
zu schwimmen
ich bin so 2 1 1 zwischen 1 und 2 ich
bin vier
[Musik]
beeinträchtigen kann
ein zwei drei vier fünf oder geht gar
nicht mehr gibt
Alter nein
wenn du mir drei Sachen in 5 Sekunden
die du jeden Tag zum Leben brauchst 1,2
Salat
Pizza
[Musik]
nein
ich dachte wegen Nudeln weil das Ändern
am Ende gefehlt hat ich liebe dich ohne
karenza aber du verstehst mich nicht
warum Du leben nicht mehr irgendwie voll
traurig Entschuldigung
kein Fahrrad fahren
ich glaube wir waren noch nie so ähnlich
am lachen ja war schon sehr gut wenn es
euch gefallen tschüss